THEY ARE THE BEST TEAM IN THE
LEAGUE.
>> THE STARS ARE TEAM
THAT HAS WON N  TO TAKE A
QUALITY SCORING CHANCE AWAY FROM
CHINO.MALKIN, HE WANTS
TO PUCK ALL THE TIME.
HE DEMANDS IT,  KUCHEROV, PUTS
ACROSS.
POINT, TAKES THE PUCK WIDE.
SHOVELS  THE C C
REBOUND CLEARED,BELMAR,
GOT BURIED IN THE CORNER WAY
OUT OF POSITION., MAKING THEM.
KEEPING THEM DOWN BELOW NO PROB
BETWEEN THE BENCHES.RTER WITH A
REACH OF HIS TRYING TO FIND
DOESN'T QUITECOMING OUTSIDE THE
THE TEAMS REMAIN AT BUT THEY SI.
JUST WENT WIDE.
>> RUNNING SOME PLAYS
>> MARINO, JEFF
IT JUST COMES OUT OVER THE
LINE.
SCHUSTER,  PALAT, TRYING TO GET
FREE.
WAS IN ON THE  ISSHOT BY FRONT.
REBOUND, JERRY, HIT IT OUT.RUST
KUCHEROV,  COLLILI
FRIEDMAN, THE COLLISION
THE TURNOVER MEANS THAT
DUMOULIN, OF THE HEAD TO  RUST,
STAMKOS, BACK TO VICTOR HEDMAN.
THAT WAS THE BEST EXAMPLE OF
THE INSIDE THE
BLUE LINE.
I DON'T